et en réalité ça fait quinze ans que
quand on collectionne les enquêtes
chaque année celle du cevipof sur l'état
de l'opinion et c'est comme ça qu'une
forme de radicalisation de l'opinion
donc pour cette raison là il y aurait
une majorité il y aurait une
potentiellement une majorité électorale
à faire sur cette question mais en fait
c'est les forces politiques qui peuvent
l'incarner sont tellement et parce que
finalement ça samsam aboutie jamais donc
peut-être que zemmour est en train de
changer la donne et qu' il va finir par
catalyse et tout ça et qu'il est porté
par ce courant et que ça le le portera
encore plus haut je n'en sais rien moi
ce que j'écoute dans ce que vous dites
est ce que je questionne c'est la
capacité de marine le pen qui a choisi
une autre stratégie en réalité à
incarner une alternative et médiamat
combien je vous promets qu'après je
parlais de la gauche parce que ça
m'intéresse également mais en fait
d'ailleurs j'y viens marine le pen a
choisi dès 2012 d'ailleurs elle venait
d'hériter du parti de son père elle
avait fait une première candidature à la
présidentielle et elle se retrouve en
situation de commencer son aventure
politique elle échoue aux portes du
second tour et et c'est pas humiliant à
l'époque et elle choisit au lieu de
tendre la main aux électeurs de droite
déçus par part par la défaite de nicolas
sarkozy l'arrivée du socialiste françois
hollande etc elle choisi de tendre la
main aux électeurs de mélenchon plutôt
pour essayer justement tout si tu es ce
que vous appelez de vos voeux c'est à
dire cette majorité enfin c'est ce bloc
populaire et en fait ça fait dix ans
qu'elle essaye et ça fait dix ans que ça
ne fonctionne pas moi c'est ça que je
questionne ça fait dix ans que l a
progressé en temps et elle a plafonné et
en 2017 on a compris que celle là
portait qu'à 33 % des voix et depuis
elle régresse aux municipales elle
régresse en nombre de voix alors oui
d'abstention vient tempérer tout cette
analyse mais est original aussi et elle
s'en sort moins bien que d'autres partis
donc ma question c'est finalement il ya
un affrontement entre deux intellectuels
qui sont jérôme sainte marie et patrick
buisson c'est ça qui est aujourd'hui en
jeu mais c'est vrai patrick buisson
pendant des années je sais qu'après il a
changé d'avis il est venu sur votre
ligne mais il a expliqué que la droite
ne pouvait gagner que si elle faisait
l'alliance justement de la bourgeoisie
patriotes dont parle eric zemmour et des
classes populaires d'autres comme vous
prétendre que le bloc populaire peut
suffire jeu j'aimerais juste comprendre
dans quelle mesure sa fin sur quoi vous
fondez pour penser ça parce qu'en
réalité quand on voit la stratégie de
marine le pen finalement je trouve que
lé demont - en mesure d'accéder et
l'arrivée de zemmour le prouve une fois
de plus d'accéder aux responsabilités
à cause de cette stratégie
[Musique]